to understand the pyromancers you have
to go back once again to valaria and the
toydarians
the Valerians were sorcerers and they
practiced blood magic they practiced
fire magic they tamed and rowed and
deployed in war dragons but valaria was
destroyed and then the only surviving
dragons were the Targaryen dragons and
even they died out so the pyromancers or
alchemists are a group of would-be
sorcerers who are attempting to to
recreate fire metric with the spells and
what also with alchemy with mixing
things and they have not succeeded to
the extent of the Valerians did but they
have succeeded to a certain extent in
creating what they call the substance
and what the rest of the world called
wildfire it's really nasty stuff but
it's hard to make and they keep within
this guild of param answers they keep
the secret of it of making it very very
private very secret only only their own
acolytes and eventual masters the
wisdoms as they call themselves know how
to make wildfire
you never hear about all the prophecies
that undoubtedly people made it didn't
come true you just hear about the ones
that did come true or that came true in
in some unexpected way you know which is
the thing you have to do if you're a
fantasy writer and you're writing about
prophecies you know you you try to pay
them off in ways that are not that the
reader doesn't necessarily see is he
coming
and I've had some fun with prophecies in
the book you know in the second season
and the second book one of the devices
that I opened with his two is the red
comet where this you know this red comet
appears in the sky and through ancient
times and medieval times the appearance
of comments was always seen as the sign
of the gods sending us a message and so
it is in Westeros except like eight of
my characters are all looking at the red
comet and they're all interpreting it
differently they will say oh yes it's a
slide you know the Lannisters are saying
you know look it's a red comet and red
is our thing it means for us and Stannis
is thinking it's for him and Dany and
the east is seeing a red comet and
interpreting it as something meaning
something to her so you know these signs
and portents can be can be seen in many
many different ways and I've had some
fun with that
the white Ravens are sent forth from by
the maesters and Archmage's to the
Citadel only when a season changes they
use regular ordinary black Ravens for
ordinary messages but when their
observations of the Stars and of snows
and weather climates and temperatures
that are being sent to them by maesters
from all over the Seven Kingdoms caused
them to conclude that the the season has
changed
they send forward to white Ravens to the
important Lords as as a Herald of this
fact to tell them that it's time to
change their policy because you know
when autumn comes which is which is what
has happened when summer ends and autumn
arrives then winter is next so you had
better start making preparations for
that you had better start putting food
aside put holding back a portion of each
harvest and putting it in your granaries
and your vaults and you know stocking up
firewood and other goods and calling
your herds so you won't have so many
animals to feed through the winter and
doing all of the things that you need to
do if you're gonna have a hope of
surviving a winter that's about to
descend on you and we don't know how
long it's going to last